that looks a right I guess yeah it looks
good oh hey what's up guys I'm Paul
biset and I'm ke Yandle and this is our
first ever episode of yling business and
we're in Seattle Washington for a coffee
making contest against two of the Kraken
Brandon tth AKA turbo and Andre
burkovski so uh looks like we better get
practicing because we got our work cut
out for
[Music]
us where then with
good to see you Keith nice you thanks so
much for doing this Budd hey I heard
this guy doesn't drink coffee though no
I do I just too lazy to make one I we go
buy one so so we're we're going to be
doing a coffee making contest we don't
know what we're doing you guys
definitely don't know what you're doing
but Brandy knows what she's doing and
she's going to give us a crash course on
everything we need to know about making
the perfect cup of coffee little round
of applause here Brandy thank you very
much of course of course latte art takes
a lot of work and practice uh you guys
are going to going get a crash course in
it and then I'm going to show you how to
pull your espresso shots you only get
one shot at this I'm going to help you
steam one picture of milk and then you
guys are going to build your signature
Beverages and then I am going to judge
them awesome are you ready for it are
you going to taste them too that's the
only way to judge but is it latte you
make like the nice like little picture
on I want to see the latte art on top
that's what I'm going to teach you guys
to
do okay from here you're going to dose
your shot of espresso
so ideally we're looking for a nice even
T how many shots could kill somebody
like 10 shots of espresso would they
have a Jammer I think 600 milligrams of
caffeine is actually um caffeine
intoxication which should be about yeah
about five shots I want to say want to
try it boys I had one game I was a
little tired
I like around 1,000 Mig you did
was heart attack I swear to God I got
pull off the game and like AKG all over
me is this in Colorado defibrillator on
the bench with the elevation in Colorado
yeah that's crazy lost my mission okay I
need I need an amb that's how Biz
[Music]
played now because I hold it with my
left hand I'm going to kick the bottom
out directly to the left about 20° this
splashes you in the face it's game over
and does every person that works in
coffee shop do this angles and stuff
like that ideally feel like the guy my
local dunies isn't uh is doing he's
talking a Lou what you again here comes
the Tilt so 45 PR up high right in the
middle we're building it up C motion
four now to the lip of the cup so we're
dropping it
down
wow that is stun that looks like a M
tree a spice oh and a Hearts oh my
goodness there's no chance I'm this are
you guys ready I'm ready give it a shot
all
right and then go ahead and lean same
pressure those jeans are applying to
your
quads that's pretty hey I'll give you a
pre a pre- clap too you Fisher has one
of these machines at home we got the
skill guys and now we got the
plumbers does that look like a good drip
so far it actually looks pretty good
looks a little watered down for my taste
but you you think talk Ronnie and a
dropping 20 20 G's on one of these for
the locker room they probably have one
we have one it has never worked though
oh no no that's perfect me and Biz will
come fix
it you're off a little bit you got to go
a little more right yeah we got hecklers
in the crowd
yans so keep your hand away from the
bottom well oh there we go he's on the
that's what you did is going to be
calling it I like mine extra hot I want
to burn the the customer's
throat L work for a cup not even a cup
right
[Music]
there
oh wow yes grabb the other one no no no
did
you that's a dove man that's a dove been
friend from Home Alone man
Turtle oh no buddy look pretty this was
going so well looks like a radish yeah
absolutely look like that's a broken
heart
right I didn't do it bro where you you
you got nothing in
[Music]
there tastes like every other
cup that was just the first comp that
was just a little bit of a warm-up now
we're going to get into the real
competition and we're going to make our
own custom coffees not this like
unoriginal type stuff right it's going
to be me and Yan vers you two so we're
going to pair up here and uh and now
we're really going to show you his boss
best of luck fell
this stuff is not no
good take them away chocolate caramel
caramel that's not a bad idea four shots
of espresso cuz that's spicy spicy and
you're going to love it which part do
you want to
do I'm I'm I think I got a whole of the
design part right now so if you create
it I can stir it or whatever it's called
then we're going to go pistachio milk
and they
if we can get some real pistachio milk
it's going to have that crunch to it so
you get a little nibble at the end I
think it's going to be pretty damn Elite
all who's first were you rock paper
scissors let's go
baby thank
you love that pressure y I think I'd be
the best press guy you need to put
pressure pach milk never had I've never
heard of that why are you
shaking I am too
if you steal our ingredients it's a
point dedu we're going original but like
they make it
idly talk me through this so so we tilt
it and then right through the middle
middle yep towards you what do you mean
then you're going to pull it towards you
no yeah down yeah and through and yeah
out towards me towards me now commit go
straight yeah dude that's Christmas
right there you kidding me Chris
Kringle we present to you wow that
you're going to love it
what do we have in here so we have four
shots of espresso good thing I don't
work tomorrow it's it's with a side of
heart attack a side of heart oh now
you're trying to butter me up and then
we used pistachio milk we didn't have
turmeric so we decided to go with
cinnamon and around the lip we did a
caramel sauce just to sweeten it up a
little bit cuz you've been so sweet to
us today I have to be honest I am
absolutely terrified to try this B do
you want me to try it for
you oh God that's not the face you want
initially it's a little
intense that might be the worst cup of
coffee I've ever had I think the
cinnamon might I think it's not bad I
think it's not terrible yeah sweet it
might have change your PL little I was
going to give it
a
three7 out of 10 out five no out of five
out of five nice out of out of 10 oh God
all righty guys now here bu there we go
did they give you any type of background
information on what they're making uh
just original we're going classic I
thought that our breakdown of what we
were going into meant something and that
should have that should have played a
little bit more on the score 27 clean
clean the wand as berky on
anything he's The
Decorator oh this is going to
nice to the brim and going keep going
keep going commit commit
wow go keep going Brandon you can be a
coach when you uh retire yeah nothing
happen we need more there to the bottom
yeah f for
effort oh shock going for the cinnamon
spice just like
us we present you the Christmas latte
Christmas Ella it's berky's daughter a
okay and they're trying to
get Prett that
know is there something sweet in here we
did is is it carel car and maple at the
bottom season tickets too or what all
right you guys could have stirred your
drink better okay syrup and sauce sit at
the bottom a little
bit has a very nice texture for a latte
whoever steamed the milk did a great job
dude good job I'm giving you guys a
solid seven oh my God cring grade too
all
wow but this is why I'm putting this in
front of my stall we should go sit down
and enjoy these cups of coffee and uh
get to know you guys a little bit better
I know we were in the midst of
competition we want to hear about your
guys uh your guys time in Seattle Randy
we want to thank you for being an
amazing teacher some of you great at
breaking everything down and it's
unfortunate that we just that might be
higher than a seven execute steamed
milk it was an honor having you boys on
the first ever yling business and you
guys took down the the crown as the
Champs of the first ever episodes how do
you feel about that might not be able to
sleep tonight with all the coffee but it
was a hell of a time both you guys
coming from more traditional hockey
markets you know Colorado uh Pittsburgh
stuff like that it's is do you feel the
same type of energy with the fan base
here as he did in other cities that you
played in I think it's almost uh almost
better year our F has been unbelievable
um every game since I've been here at
least so um they come every game to
support even winner lose it's so great
to see hockey flourishing you know
especially with the youth and the love
the city has for it in 15 20 years
you're going to see kids from Seattle
playing in the NHL and I can only
imagine how much that would mean to
someone like you guys that you know you
had the impact in these kids last cuz
you see it all like Arizona you get
Austin Matthews Florida guys like that
there's a handful of guys that are from
the state but like you said like the
game is growing so quick and so fast
you're that we're going to have that
next great player from Washington coming
into the NHL what's haxall like he seems
like a very uh serious tense guy is he
is does he ever joke around with you
guys does he ever loosen up a little bit
he does for sure I mean he is a I think
he's more he looks more tense than
intimidating when you're looking at the
Ben is a hack's an incredible guy he's a
great person and a great coach um I
think you know kind of how intense and
how much he enjoys coaching and the love
for the game maybe that kind of Echoes
on his personality more but you know
when you're kind of conversing on a
day-to-day basis and away from the rank
it's it's easy flowing it's it's a great
conversation um but when do things get
to the game it's important for us to to
kind of be in the the moment and present
I think he does a great job of kind of
leveling us out and getting us ready to
play who who are the tough guys that
reel in as far as the having too much
fun the court Jesters as I call them in
the locker who who who are the guys in
the locker room keeping everybody loose
I'd probably say uh I mean bery and
myself do like to have a have a lot of
fun probably us too yeah I'm probably a
little bit more like the loud guy likes
to joke around even like before games
and stuff like that keeping it Loose
he's a little bit more like I was trying
to talk to him a little bit before
before the game yesterday and I was like
nice talk he doesn't he just doesn't
Turbo Turbo he's
like so how how did you end up at a
wedding with Mario and what's the story
of you being too intimidated to ask him
for a cigar the year I signed in
Pittsburgh kind of became friends with
um uh Mario's daughter's husband his
name's Noah and he's great friends with
Mario's son Austin so I got invited to
to the wedding and it was like I you
know you can't say no to this this is
one of those opportunities where you got
to go and it's going to be a great time
we were sitting there and the big guys
you know Mario was out there with um
Pierre and Ty and were getting cigars
going it was late and I'm like Army I
was nagging at army I'm like you know
get us a cigar and so yeah in time time
he kept asking me I'm like Army come on
like what do you say like cigars and
like I didn't want to go over there I
was just happy to be at the wedding yeah
and uh we had enough shots and drinks
finally for him to go over there and
asked him for uh for a cigar and he came
back and he was grinning and I was like
that's that's awesome and then you know
you go over there and thank Mario and
thae but with those guys and how much
experience they've played in the league
you kind of just want to be there and
listen to the stories that those those
guys were were talent I mean it was a a
great time but you know Army didn't me a
solid there so were you able to actually
get some of the stories out of Mario and
sit down and enjoy a full cigar with
them I was just sitting there I wasn't
saying much I was just you know having a
good stoy but they were shooting the
[__] and telling stories and I was just
kind of for the first time in my life I
was listening jaw dropped yeah well we
got you a gift cuz it's your birthday
tomorrow right night day before the
Winter Classic so you don't have to be
nervous about asking us for stoies so we
got you it's tubo not turbo they forgot
the r but a good tment and uh and you
can enjoy one too maybe
after thank you guys for being a part of
the
first and luck in the Winter Classic and
in the rest of the season
boys